i'm learning new country this winter so
my greatest challenge
is don't let the land or the weather
kill me
the water is cold
you feel get used to it after a while
this is a
big chunk of ice
rico and skyler have traveled to the
celawat hot springs with plans to break
trail for vital resources
but with potentially catastrophic
flooding underneath the cabins on the
grounds the duo must act quickly to
ensure the safety of the structures
if they are unable to stop the water
from damaging the foundations the cabins
won't last
it warmed up out here today so gave us a
little opportunity to start working on
this water situation
basically got the flood plain by
creating a channel of all this water
going over the dam and alongside of the
cabin instead of through the cabin all
this grass and mustard was insulating
the warm rocks and mud at the bottom so
when it gets real cold it's freezing all
the way to the bottom creating a huge
flood plain out here
what i'm trying to do is break away all
this
moss grass willows roots
expose that warm rocks and mud and
hopefully that keeps it from freezing
down and just has a natural
creek to flow through all winter
it's basically a band-aid though because
once it gets real cold it might freeze
all the way down again and create this
whole flood plain to start up again
eventually that beaver house has to be
destroyed
so there's no water flowing around or
next to the cabins at all and just no
hope for a flood plain happening again
people out here we depend on these
cabins and we depend on it every year
for generations and we let these cabins
get eliminated by water and ice
that could easily eliminate someone's
life that's coming out here unprepared
thinking they have a nice spot to get
cozy in and dry off
not only that there's water over the
snow machine trail and if you go in that
thing and get hurt end up in the water
and you come in and the cabins are
glaciered over with ice and water
you're in a bad spot
[Music]
here's a mysterious black bird
first time we've seen them was when i
was a kid
it has this pointed beak doesn't have
webbed feet but it swims
it dives
it hunts fish way up here in the head
waters it dries itself off in the snow
and then it hangs out in the trees it's
unique only to these areas i really
don't even know if that bird's been
discovered yet if there's no name for
that bird it's a new one
it's gonna be the dewily bird
okay let's check it out
damn look at this
there's no more water going underneath
the cabin
yeah i remember this it was just flowing
right here
this will help out a lot
all this driving over with a snowmachine
was a big old deal whoa
oh this is hanging nice now
check out the snow machine trail and as
you can see
the water has quit flowing
see the trail looks a whole lot better
real gratifying feeling basically saving
cabins by playing in a puddle so
a little tired now i'm glad we got the
job done let's go inside
take a break
we're gonna get to bed early
tomorrow we have a lot of work to do
[Music]
you